this is Jocko podcast number 162 with
echo Charles and me Jocko willing good
evening echo good evening
on the 22nd of April 2008 two marine
battalions the 1st battalion 9th Marines
the walking dead from Vietnam Fame and
the second battalion 8th Marines were
switching out in Ramadi Iraq one
battalion going home in a few days and
the other just starting it's a
seven-month tour to Marines corporal
Jonathan Yale and lance corporal Jordan
herder 22 and 20 years old respectively
one from each battalion they were
assuming the watch together at the
entrance gate to an outpost that
contained a makeshift barracks housing
50 Marines the same broken-down
ramshackled building was also home to a
hundred Iraqi police they were my men in
this fight against the terrorists in
Ramadi Yale was a dirt-poor mixed race
kid from Virginia with a wife and a
daughter and a mother and a sister who
lived with them and he supported them as
well on $13,000 a year herder was a
middle-class white kid from Long Island
the two of them were from two completely
different worlds in our country not good
not bad just different had they not
joined the Marine Corps they would never
have known each other they would never
have even understood that multiple
Americas exists simultaneously depending
on your education level your family's
income status maybe but they
Marines they were combat Marines and
because of this bond they were brothers
as close as if they were born to the
same woman the mission orders they
received from the sergeant their squad
leader I am sure went something like
this
okay you two clowns stand this post and
let no unauthorized personnel or
vehicles pass you clear on that I'm also
sure that Yale and herder then rolled
their eyes and said in unison something
like yeah sergeant we got it we know
what we're doing with just enough
attitude that made the point without
saying the words no kidding sweetheart
we know what we're doing
they then relieved the two other Marines
on watch who turns out we're probably
the two luckiest Marines on earth that
day and they assumed their post at the
entry control point at joint security
station Nasser in the sophia district of
Ramadi Iraq a few minutes later a large
blue truck turned down the alleyway the
alleyway was no more than 100 yards in
length and sped its way through the
serpentine of Jared concrete jersey
walls the truck stopped just short of
where the two were posted and detonated
killing them both catastrophic Lee if
you know what combat is like you know
what I'm talking about when I say
catastrophic Lee twenty-four brick
masonry houses were damaged or destroyed
by the blast a mosque a hundred yards
away collapsed
the trucks engine came to rest 200
meters away
knocking most of a building down before
it stopped our aod guys our explosive
guys reckons the blast was made of at
least 2,000 pounds of explosives two
died then because these two young
infantrymen didn't have it in their DNA
to run from danger a hundred and fifty
men fifty US Marines and 100 Iraqis were
saved when I read the situation report
about the incident a few hours after it
happened I called the regimental
commander and I asked him for details of
what had happened it seemed different to
me unfortunately Marines dying or being
seriously wounded is common in combat we
expect Marines and for that matter
soldiers sailors airmen and Coast
Guardsmen regardless of rank or MOS to
do their duty to stand their ground and
do their duty and to die if that's what
the mission requires the regimental
commander had just returned from the
site and he agreed with me but reported
that there were no American witnesses to
the event just Iraqi police I figured if
there was any chance of finding out what
actually happened and then to recognize
and decorate these two young Marines and
acknowledge their bravery I'd have to do
it myself because I understood that the
bureaucrats back in Washington would
never accept Iraqi statements for what
had taken place if getting these Marines
properly awarded had any chance at all
it had to come under my signature as a
general officer
so I traveled to Ramadi the next day and
spoke individually to a half-dozen Iraqi
police all of whom told the same story
they said the blue truck turned down
into the alley and immediately sped up
as it made its way through the
serpentine jersey walls they all said
they knew immediately what was going on
particularly as the Marines began to
fire the Iraqi police all began firing
as well
then to a man they ran for safety just
prior to the explosion they all survived
many were injured some seriously injured
one of the Iraqis said to me that they
had all run from the danger like any
normal man would to save his own life
what he didn't know until then what he
learned that very day was that Americans
are not normal with tears welling up he
said sir in the name of God no sane man
would have stood there and done what
they'd done no sane man they saved all
of us
what we didn't know at the time and what
I didn't know at the time and only
learned a couple of days later after I
wrote a summary of this bravery and
submitted it and submitted them both
Yale and herder for the Navy crosses
which is the number two award for
Marines and sailors in combat what I
didn't know was that one of our security
cameras that we had at the location that
was damaged initially in the blast had
caught everything it had happened
exactly as the Iraqis had described it
to me that took exactly six seconds by
that recording from when the truck
entered the alley until it exploded six
seconds
and you can watch and I did watch many
many times on this recording the last
six seconds of their young lives when it
first started I suppose it took a second
or so for the marines to separately come
to the same conclusion about what was
going on they had no time to talk it
over only enough time to take half an
instant and think about what the
sergeant had told them to do only a few
minutes before let no unauthorized
personnel or vehicles pass at that point
in the recording the two Marines had
about five seconds left to live it took
maybe another two seconds for the two
jarheads to raise their weapons take aim
and open fire on the truck by this time
the truck was half way through the
barriers and gaining speed the whole
time here the recording shows a number
of Iraqi policemen some of whom had
fired their aks now scattering like the
normal and rational men they were some
running right past the Marines the two
Marines had about three seconds left to
live for about two seconds more the
recording shows the Marines weapons
firing non-stop the trucks windshield
exploded into shards of glass as their
rounds took it apart and undoubtedly
tore into the body of this terrorists
that was trying to kill their brothers
unaware of the danger at the time the
other Marines and Iraqi soldiers in the
barracks could take comfort in the fact
that two Marines were on watch and would
die before they ran
the recording shows the truck careening
to a stop immediately in front of the
two Marines in all of this instantaneous
violence Yale and hurdler never
hesitated they never stepped the back
they never even started to step back
they never even shifted their weight
with their feet spread shoulder-width
apart they leaned into the danger firing
as fast as they could they only had one
second left to live then the truck
explodes the camera goes blank
and the two young men go to their god 6
seconds not enough time to think about
their families their country their flag
or about their lives or their deaths but
more than enough time for two very brave
young men to do their duty into eternity
that is the kind of people the Quran
watch all over the world tonight for you
and that was a speech that was given by
Marine Corps general general Kelly and
he gave the speech to gold star families
these are families who have lost a
service member killed in action and he
gave that speech on February 21st 2014
and general Kelly was obviously speaking
from the heart not only was he the
commanding general in charge of those
Marines but he also understands loss on
a very personal level because on
November 9th 2010 general Kelly's oldest
son 1st lieutenant Robert Michael Kelly
was killed in action by a landmine while
he was on patrol leading a platoon of
Marines in Afghanistan and that story of
those two Marines is yet another example
of the dedication and the devotion of
the Marines and we know full well that
there is example after example after
example from all our branches of service
examples
of sacrifice and you can think about
those six seconds six seconds we throw
those away all the time we can waste
hours and days we can even waste weeks
as if we have an endless supply but we
don't if you were giving six seconds to
live
what would fill your mind would you be
okay with that would you nod your head
and think okay it's time
or would you be filled with regret in
those last moments would you think about
what you should have done what you
should have said who you should have
been and in the end would you realize
that there's no reason ever to waste six
seconds of your life
that is one lesson we can take away from
general Kelly's speech six seconds can
be an eternity
another lesson we can take away from
this speech and from its author knowing
that general Kelly had lost his son is
that we have to move forward we have to
move on and this isn't to say don't feel
anything because that's wrong and that
is not what we are doing I mean who can
fathom the pain that general Kelly felt
at the loss of his eldest son as his
eldest son pursued a career that was no
doubt inspired by the general himself
but he moved on he drove on
I was talking to a friend of mine and we
were talking about survivor's guilt
which is something that we all feel on
some level when we're in the military
and sometimes I think people feel as if
there's something wrong with them or
they feel like they're weak because they
let their emotions get ahold of them
sometimes and I could see my friend just
feeling that and I told him about an
interview that I did with Colonel Tom
Fife on this podcast the he was an Army
officer that had served in World War two
Korea and Vietnam he'd gotten a Purple
Heart in all three Wars and I explained
to my friend that as Colonel Fife and I
were discussing the men that he lost in
Vietnam Colonel Fife got choked up
Colonel Fife got choked up despite the
fact that 51 years had passed since he
lost those men 51 years but he still got
emotional why is that it's because we
care about our men because we care about
each other and it's because while we
hear that time heals all wounds time
does not remove the scars they are going
to be there and they're going to hurt
and that's okay and that's normal it's
normal to feel the pain and it's normal
to feel the guilt and I think that's one
of the hardest things for vets that I
talk to is that they don't think that
this is normal but I am Telling You it
is normal every vet that I've talked to
from World War two Vietnam the guys that
have served in Iraq and Afghanistan
everyone feels it it's part of the deal
it's part of the job it's part of the
aftermath of war it's always existed and
if you're feeling that then you should
know that you are not alone
what else do we learn from this
speech well another thing opens up a
whole a whole box a whole Pandora's box
of lessons learned we're talking about
urban combat and how fast things can
unfold their urban combat is
exceptionally stressful the the
space-time continuum in urban combat is
very compressed the threats are 360
degrees the enemy can be they give me
500 meters away but they can also be 5
meters away in one of the ways that we
can mitigate that stress and thereby
mitigate casualties and thereby mitigate
the guilt that we all carry is by
knowing an understanding that form of
combat to the best of our ability and as
always history has much to teach us
then I want to go now to a direct source
the leadership from Charlie 1:5 Charlie
Company 1st battalion 5th Marines
Charlie 1:5 fought in the Battle of Wei
city a brutal battle that took place
during the Tet Offensive Vietnam 1968
the battle lasted from January 30th to
March 4th included 11 arvin battalions
for US Army battalions 3 US Marine Corps
battalions support from the Air Force
and they were fighting against a
strength of about 10 enemy battalions it
was a massive battle and Wei was a
built-up city it had a population of
almost 150,000 people it had
typical urban terrain and also some
unique terrain like the Citadel which
was a massive walled portion of the city
by the time it was over the enemy had
lost thousands of men killed the South
Vietnamese had lost 452 men and America
suffered two hundred and sixteen men
killed in action and 1584 wounded in
action and here are some quotes from an
interview from the digital journalists
with a guy by the name of John Olsen an
army combat photographer who is in way
during this battle he said I was in way
for five days I'd been in Vietnam for
one year at this time I had seen a lot
of battles and I thought I was pretty
experienced but I'd never seen anything
like way there was tremendous bravery a
lot of dead there was a situation in way
where we had Marines in a courtyard they
had been moving from house to house in
transition here across this courtyard
they had rocketed a lot of them were
wounded there was no radio contact we
were pinned down and in pretty bad shape
we had an ailment that eventually came
to interleave us and it had a priest
then he gave last rites to the dead and
he was a very generous priest he offered
to give the last rites to any of us that
wanted them dead wounded or not
scratched at that point in context it
was such a horrific battle with such
horrific images hue was different
there were tremendous casualties and no
way to treat them no way to get them
taken out there were reports and as
shown in this image there was a marine
who was badly wounded so badly he
couldn't be treated then he was zipped
up in a body bag while he was still
alive
that's what way was like I was in way
for five days and we were under heavy
fire all the time one of my favorite
quotes was a journalist
asking a marine how many times he had
been wounded in a way and he said today
sir
so it was a brutal battle and there was
just incredible heroism and sacrificed
and of course there were many lessons
learned and while the lessons focus on
urban combat and they focus on the
battle waste city I think as you hear
some of these lessons learned you'll see
they apply broadly to leadership as a
whole and as we know if we understand
the way we can see it in all things so
let's go to this document lessons
learned Charlie one five operation away
city 31 January 1968 to five March 1968
even under the best of circumstances
street fighting is a bloody business
this was in the end the ultimate lesson
learned by the United States Marine
Corps personnel who participated in this
historical battle considered by many to
be the bloodiest of the Vietnam War
the marine forces involved in operation
away city lost 142 Marines killed in
action during the month-long battle
including the initial fierce clashes
involving primarily fighting throughout
the southern sections of the city and
climactic full-scale battles inside the
Citadel fortress itself hundreds more
Marines were wounded and had to be
medevacked on both sides of the river
enemy casualties estimates range well
into the thousands
although operation wasted he will long
be remembered as an overwhelming victory
over the best conventional forces the
enemy could throw at us and although the
fifth Marines overcame very unfavorable
odds and ultimately triumphed in the
finest traditions of Marines in combat
in truth this battle was a very close
thing at the squad platoon and company
levels casualty rates were very severe
as high as 75% or more in some units
this was especially true during the
first day of day or two of each units
initial experience in full-scale urban
combat there's an important piece right
there especially heavy casualties during
the first day or two of a unit going
into combat what does that mean that
means then that first day into day or
two you are learning a ton and that also
means that if you can find out and
figure out how to simulate that combat
before you enter into those situations
you'll be able to overcome or at least
mitigate some of those initial shock
things that happen that shock your
system and you're not ready for them and
you know I talked about this with with
doing jujitsu
for instance for females right if you're
a female that wants to learn
self-defense and you you know you start
training jujitsu
if you don't train jujitsu and some guy
grabs ahold of you you're a year in
shock you're not used to it
you haven't you you have to contend with
that something that you're unaccustomed
to hmm if you train jujitsu guess what
you have guys grabbing you every single
day they're grabbing you they're
grinding on you they're trying to move
you you're used to that you don't have
to overcome that same thing with
the closer you can get to simulating
what you're gonna face in combat the
better you're gonna do in combat and you
don't have to learn these horrible
lessons your first entry and you know
you and I have talked about this too if
you get if if let's say I learned a new
move in jujitsu mm-hmm and I did it to
you you you'd I'd catch you
and then I show it to you and all of a
sudden I can't barely catch you anymore
right that's all it took all it takes is
you knowing and understanding and it's
the same thing when we talk with
businesses and we do we do role-playing
exercises as the leader and how do you
talk how do you tell someone that they
need to improve their performance you do
a couple role plays and you get good at
their objections that they're gonna give
you or the reactions that they're gonna
have you can get better if you wait
until the real thing you're not doing
yourself any favors yeah yes kind of
like an ambush right like an ambush is
so effective but if you know that which
is coming exactly it's not it's not even
effective at all yeah yeah and once
you've been ambushed like imagine I mean
it happens all the time any any time you
expand understand what's gonna happen
you're infinitely more equipped to
handle that thing yeah as opposed to I
have no idea what's happening and I'm
gonna go and figure it out on the fly
yeah so experience is the best but guess
what experience is expensive it takes a
lot of time so what you have to do is
you have to train yeah that's what you
have to do what if the only time you
what if you wanted to get good at street
fighting
and the only time that you got to
practice was when you got in a street
fight right yeah even if you literally
went out every day and got into street
fights two things would happen number
one you get arrested but number two you
get all the first street fight
you might pick the wrong person and die
yes that is true right yeah so what you
want to do is you want to get into a
training environment yes and then you
want to get yourself skilled yeah
same thing with the military same thing
with fighting same thing with shooting
same thing with business anything that
you're doing it's another thing I see
like business people there's business
people that have been through let's say
they've been through an AK was it an
acquisition before they know what to
expect they're anticipating what's going
on
and it makes them that better at
foreseeing what's gonna happen in
mitigating the risk to it yeah how do
you if you can't go through the
acquisition well what do you do read
about them steal the interview people
learn about figure out what to expect
the hire someone on your team that has
been through an acquisition before so
you get can capitalize on their
experience yeah yeah it's crazy I guess
when you think about not crazy but it's
interesting so you know like sports
teams for example like uh well I I guess
football say football for an example you
practice for like five or six days just
practice practice practice to sometimes
more hours every single day you know
maybe a day off maybe and then yeah for
one game yeah so it's like there's
training then there's performance kind
of thing and they go kinda hand in hand
like you got a performing training and
then you you know the game or whatever
that you learn stuff during the game too
but it's it's interesting where one game
is predicated on so much training yeah
so much training but then when you go to
work it's like you you kind of expect to
have gone or they expect you or whatever
the expectation is that you went through
your training already and then they'll
add sprinkles of training you're talking
about like work just normal yeah when
you go to work yeah yeah great so every
once in while you'll have but we're at
least quite honestly that's that's one
of the reason s law national in front is
doing well because people are realizing
that if you want your leaders to know
how to lead you actually have to train
them how to lead and that you can
actually do that yeah so that's one of
the reasons that it's you know on front
is in such high demand because we can
actually train your leaders to handle
these situations that are coming up
against them when you do that you have
this massive advantage and we see the
companies that we work with they they
their performance just improves
immensely because their leaders are
working together and learning how to
lead and it's the most powerful thing
you can have yeah it's it's weird
because I you know I'm kind of behind
the scenes guy with yeah exelon friend
and I see like you know any video that's
been done up
you know and I'm around you know all the
time so essentially I'm getting the
course too you know and it's interesting
where I think probably in a lot of cases
I probably am more trained in it than
most people even most people companies
that you work with or whatever because
I'm kind of getting it secondhand and
listening because it applies to everyday
life you know like this whole deal it's
not just work isn't you know in fact for
me I mean yeah it applies to my
quote-unquote work but it applies to
like family stuff yeah you know wife
stuff and the big thing this is the big
thing this is a big difference you know
the material you but you because your
position you use it on your family but
you don't use it in a work environment
and therefore you get to learn the
technique but you don't get to roll you
don't get to spar not as hard and here's
the thing when we work with companies
it's not like oh here's this information
and then they go apply it perfectly ya
know they come back and say hey this
didn't work yeah I wouldn't talk to God
he said that's like okay cool yeah
here's how you gotta overcome that so
there's you got to get the initial
information yes but you still have to
apply it even if you train a group for
combat as much as you possibly can
they're still gonna have a certain Delta
that they're gonna need to rise to when
the real real girls yeah and so we see
that with companies we see that with
individual leaders that are part of
companies where they're there and I show
up sometimes you know there's some
people out there that are just straight
up in the game yeah and they're in the
game before I even show up look like
it's the icing on the cake
and even people that have read extreme
ownership ten times they've read
dichotomy of leadership 12 times they've
listened to every single podcast and
they'll still ask questions about things
because they haven't quite put it
together yes but like they haven't
mapped it perfectly on their saturation
right and just like I said like it takes
it takes like okay how you say I don't
really get to spar I did I do get to
sparked but they're real easy super easy
sparring partners who do I got I got you
I got my wife you know yeah like you
know there's coming easy spawn
technically yeah for this for this
it is I mean technically you're the
easiest flooring partner because you're
just like you're doing the same thing
and also it's like there's no friction I
mean very little friction maybe on some
levels but there's a song but the you
know these people at work when they
apply it when you know when you have
look whether it be a corporate job or
whatever you know any time where you
have bigger teams different
personalities you know you care about
yeah on different levels it's like
anyway more it takes more effort and
more time on the mat young people to get
proficient to where you look at a
situation you go oh here's what this
here's the problem going to here this
guy's he goes get a little out of
control minute massage Zito a little bit
and it will let him have some more
control and that'll make him feel better
they'll do a better job like it takes a
little bit of experience to get to that
point yeah and and you know a lot of
times like I said when we go and work
with a company that this is fully in the
game and they'll be batting they'll be
nailing nine out of ten things and then
it'll be one more thing that they need a
little adjustment on and they make that
adjustment and they call yeah you know
everything makes sense so training is
how you get good don't waste your time
getting beat up in street fights in
order to learn it doesn't make sense all
right moving on the ultimate success of
this operation could have been
significantly improved in our opinion by
several factors including one improved
less restrictive rules of engagement
including situational flexibility down
to the platoon level this is something
we hear about all the time here's the
deal what that what that really means is
decentralized command you need to trust
your troops you need to explain to them
what is important what is not rules of
engagement to tell someone you cannot do
this mm-hmm what I'm saying if I say
echo you cannot shoot at this type of
building if I tell you that what I'm
telling you is I don't trust you to make
a good decision based on the information
I give you if I was to say hey listen
some of these buildings that are marked
with a star those buildings are
historical buildings that will cause the
civilian populace to you know get angry
at us so don't shoot at them if I say
that's you and I say telly explain to
you why it's important and then I say
hey look
then again remember you're in the field
you need to protect your men and you say
got it and now you go in the field and
if you're a good leader and you trust me
and I trust you and I've explained the
commander's intent well and you
understand the strategic impact of of
disobeying or of going outside the rules
of them that are not the rules but the
direction that I've given you then you
understand that that's great and you'll
make a good decision because what that
decision might entail is you're getting
shot at from one of these buildings and
now you have to take it down if I don't
trust you to make that decision what do
I do
I put strict rules of engagement on you
and now you can't do something yeah and
that is that is not decentralized
command yeah and it's not generally good
do you have to put some broad rules in
place yes you absolutely do but you have
to make sure that the people on the
ground understand that those rules can
be bent if they have to and they have to
have the authority and the leeway to do
that next to improved communication of
intelligence information to all levels
of command of course communicate
communication is one of those things and
again I feel I always feel when we go to
work with a company it's one of the
first things I have to ask is what are
your methodologies of communication
through your company and how do you
communicate with your frontline troops
how do you communicate with your
mid-level managers how do your mid-level
managers and your frontline troops
communicate with you because sometimes
the frontline troops might see something
out on the battlefield that you don't
see cuz you're up in the ivory tower
yeah and how do they communicate that
back to you do you have a methodology
oftentimes communication is ineffective
or it's they don't have procedures
around then a protocol on how to
communicate that's bad so communication
up and down the chain of command simple
clear and concise that's the way it's
got to be three acquisition of improved
intelligence data in particular
concerning the disposition size of enemy
forces that's cool that's a little bit
of a universal
Phantasy for military people that we
want great intelligence we want to know
where the enemy is
if we knew who the enemy is our jobs
would be like yeah so that's a that's a
universal fantasy and we should always
strive to achieve that fantasy but it's
very difficult to get to but then they
go to this reconnaissance and small unit
probes to fix enemy positions are
critical what what that means is when
you want intelligence go get it go find
it gather the Intel yourself as much as
you can for improved supporting fire
plan access to artillery naval gunfire
direct fire from armored vehicles and
air support should be judiciously
employed deployed so what does that mean
we need to cover we need cover from big
guns
cover and move five significantly
increased training for urban conflict
street fighting practice and preparation
I think we just covered that training is
always paramount six deployment of
available chemical weapons in this case
tear gas for offensive operations during
early stages of the operation these guys
use tear gas and it worked well the
North Vietnamese Army had didn't have
gas masks and they didn't like it of
course you know there's people when you
when you say chemical weapons what do we
think of we think a mustard gas there's
other you know there's nerve agents and
nerve gas that's when people generally
think of when you think of chemical
weapons but chemical weapons are also
tear gas and tear gas can be very
effective there's also some people that
can just be T F through through to your
gas yeah continuing seven improved
dissemination of operational plan
details down to the fire team level
fireteam leaders these fireteam leaders
if the fire team leaders and you're
talking about someone that's in charge
of four guys or six guys or something
like that a really small little element
if those people understand what you're
to accomplish as a team that means they
can execute at their level and make
things happen they can move the ball in
the right direction mm-hmm
if they don't know where they're
supposed to be going guess what they
can't help you yeah they can't help you
so broad guidance needs to be given
needs to be updated people need to
understand hey we're trying to move
forward trying to take this area mmm
we're trying to move across this line
everyone needs to understand that if
they don't understand that they're
they're actually no good to you if
you've got a fire team leader out on the
flank somewhere that has no idea that
you're trying to move forward or move
east or west or north that person is
just sitting there waiting for you to
tell them what to do they're almost
worthless hmm so and this also means if
you're a fireteam leader and you don't
know if you're supposed to be going
north east south west or whatever you
should be raising your hand and saying
hey what are we doing tell me what we're
doing continuing on the other side of
the scale small unit experienced
individual Marine determination the
buddy system the quick learning capacity
of Marines under combat conditions
the combined leadership officers staff
NCOs and NCOs of 1-5 at all levels and
the ultimate ability to coordinate fire
support and execute street fighting
tactics under heavy fire were factors
that won this pivotal battle despite
incredible odds high casualty rates and
the resulting turnover of officers and
NCOs so it comes down to your individual
Marines and your your frontline
leadership that make these things happen
which no doubt the military or the US
military is awesome in in the frontline
leadership and the frontline troops they
make so many things happen even in many
cases despite poor leadership you just
you just have great frontline leadership
I mean I would see that a lot you know
you get a platoon that had kind of a
marginal and if not maybe even a bad
platoon commander but you just get some
guys in a platoon that are awesome the
platoon would be awesome as long as the
leader was humble
enough to take guidance if the hunt if
leader wasn't humble enough to take
guidance he would fail because he would
just drag everyone in his terrible ways
if he if he had the common sense to say
you know what I'm gonna listen to these
guys I'm gonna let them kind of run with
it soon who do fine continuing on
certainly using 20/20 perspective of
hindsight this battle could have been
decided in even more timely and decisive
fashion reducing friendly casualty rates
in the process by paying attention to
the fundamentals of planning marine
operations proper prior planning
prevents piss-poor performance and they
actually edited out piss because their
squared away Marines sure yeah
gotta come up with a good plan and had
they done that better this is the
typical situation the hindsight's always
20/20 and I always avoid becoming a
armchair postgame critic yeah in the
military I mean I'll criticize someone
like a fighter in the UFC or whatever
yes but when it comes to military
operations it's really easy to sit back
and throw darts and say well you know I
would have done this yeah you weren't
there you didn't see it I didn't see it
I wasn't in the situation I have all the
facts now they didn't have those facts
so yeah I'm always very cautious about
fucking darts into the past and you deal
with like that kind situation you it's
and you kind of use that you actually do
you use this as even when you say you
can sit back and be a tactical genius or
whatever yes like if I don't know if I
make a video you can like sit back and
be like look at these like 10 mistakes
or 10 things or whatever meanwhile
there's like a thousand elements so 990
elements have had to be created well and
in work and all this stuff and then it's
you can just be like yeah those because
essentially those are created for you
you know you don't have to create those
things all you have to do is poke holes
in the tent and I can focus instead of
having to focus on a thousand things I
can take a broader look
and see the 10 things that you screwed
up yeah or one thing even not a 9 Mikey
flick probably just one maybe two all
right the following details regarding
the lessons learned from operation way
City are offered from the former members
of Charlie Company 1st battalion 5th
Marine Regiment 1st Marine Division who
served in combat during operation way
City and who were directly involved in
the battle with NVA forces inside the
Citadel fortress from 13 February 1968
through 5 March 1968 situation terrain
there is an infinite variety of possible
landscapes that may be confronted by a
marine force given the mission of
attacking an enemy force in urban
terrain infinite variety of possible
landscapes what does that remind me of
that reminds me of life itself when the
Tet Offensive broke out on 31 January
1968 in conventional NVA forces over in
major sections of the largest cities in
South Vietnam marine forces were
literally knee-deep in rice paddies in
jungle mud since first establishing a
beachhead in 1965 Marines had been
assigned the mission of conducting a
counterinsurgency a rural conflict
fighting for the most part a guerrilla
army the Tet Offensive changed all of
that and for the first time since the
height of the Korean War in 1954 Marines
found themselves with a mission that
involved urban combat so you have to be
able to you should never turn your back
on something I had a fighter I was
training for a fight and I was like hey
let's do some ground work you know we'll
be with you on the bottom and the dude
was strong he wasn't it wasn't a good
wrestler well let me present
a decent wrestler but not by any stretch
you know not a call that not a
competitive call address or anything
like that but solid strong very strong I
said hey man let's put you on the bottom
and the response was I'm not gonna be on
the bottom
yeah hey well even if you don't think
you're gonna be on the bottom let's
train for the unlikely event that you
happen to end up on the bottom because
it's a fight and anything happened I
don't need to I'm not gonna be on the
bottom mmhmm yeah
so we can sell where the story's going
yeah yeah he went to his fight and
fought and was on the bottom basically
the whole fight is a three-round fight
was on the bottom almost the whole time
so it was horrible yeah and why because
you can't you can't neglect one part of
the possibilities that can unfold and
even even for us when we would get ready
to deploy to Iraq we're going to Iraq
we're literally going to a desert and
gonna be in the middle of the desert and
we would still do dive operations we'd
still do maritime operations while we
were getting ready to deploy why because
we're not going to happen we don't know
whether what next war is gonna break out
so just don't neglect anything and I'll
tell you what else if you're good at a
variety of things you will be better at
everything so if all we knew how to do
is enter rooms what happens when when
that when we when we enter a building
instead of being a bunch of rooms it's a
giant warehouse though it needs to be
cleared likely you got to think about
these things but the more flexible you
are the more capabilities you have
that's what I'm looking for the more
capabilities you have the more
flexibility you have so learn different
skillsets don't neglect things
continuing on preparing to remove an
enemy battalion that has captured a 40
storey skyscraper or a college campus is
much different than it was a much
different mission than getting the enemy
squad out of a house school or Church in
a small town the common factor in all
these variations however is that in all
cases in urban combat structures
dominate the terrain studying and
assessing terrain is a fundamental issue
for marine commanders when planning
mission this this idea of terrain is so
important the way the advantage that
terrain gives you mm-hmm
is I don't know what to compare it to in
other in anything else if you understand
terrain you can dominate it's like
trying to do jiu-jitsu a not
understanding arm position yeah like
where that you need underhooks if you
know if you're going against people
don't understand onyx you will destroy
them yeah if you going against someone
that doesn't understand where to
position their hands where to position
their arms you will destroy them if
you're going against someone that
doesn't understand how to utilize the
terrain you you will destroy them if you
don't know how to utilize the terrain
you will get destroyed and by the way
that doesn't matter if you're in the
city or in the rural environment as a
matter where you are studying in
assessing terrain is a fundamental issue
for marine commanders when planning
missions this is even more critical in
planning house-to-house combat
operations building materials vary
worldwide and their ability to provide
small arms cover to a very high degree
through the use of reconnaissance and
intelligence we recommend conducting a
serious assessment of each building or
structure that is within your units area
of operations because tactics involved
in taking each objective building
structure etc may be different in each
case a small wood frame house may offer
the illusion of cover from small arms
fire but little else in some places
walls are paper-thin even houses that
use some form of plaster or concrete
construction can prove to be
unexpectedly porous and at the worst
possible times this is something to
consider all the time things are not
always what they seem
that's that's what's important there
mm-hmm things are not always what they
seem you you think you're hiding behind
a wall and now you're safe
no bullets will go right through it yeah
continuing know the basic layout of a
structure as much as possible before
entry this is something that I would say
our standard operating procedures in the
US military now are so good that we
don't really need to know that's the
layout of a structure we're gonna go in
and be able to handle whatever this
structure however the structure is laid
out
that's what we do if you don't train to
enter rooms regularly and you don't
train to enter buildings and you don't
train to be able to contend with all
these varieties of things that you could
face you won't be able to if you try and
say okay we need to know what the
building looks like inside before we go
in there that's a horrible horrible idea
it's not gonna happen and by the way
when you go in there the first thing
you're gonna come across is a barricade
well you can't go down the hallway and
you got to go through these other rooms
that you weren't expecting hmm
continuing approach each structure with
an entry plan and a search plan and make
sure each member of the fire team in
squad is well versed in these plans what
I say instead of that is not plans these
are standard operating procedures you
develop standard operating procedures so
you know what to do when you enter a
building and so does everyone on the
team establish voice codes and commands
and communicate regularly with each
other
yes consider entryways existing doors
and windows to be extremely dangerous
likely locations for Ruby traps and to
be avoided if at all possible whenever
possible blow entry holes using satchel
charges or rockets once the entry plan
is finalized and understood it must be
executed with fierce determination be
prepared for anything and be ready to
improvise be systematic and check
everything basement sewer access attics
rooftops trash cans thoroughly before
establishing that the objective is
secure so what I one of the most
important things I take away from that
is that the the existing entry ways you
got to consider them dangerous how do we
translate that into life what that means
is these well-established patterns are
exactly that and it I'm not saying you
can't ever use a pattern that someone
else used but you at least at a minimum
have to be aware of the fact that when
you're doing something when you're using
a path that someone else has already
gone down it's a known path and so you
can't expect to be able to surprise your
competitor when you're doing something
that's always been done the same way
yeah so think of how you can approach
things in a different manner
if in fact that manner might be better
sometimes you look at things from a
different angle and you realize that the
reason that everyone does it this way is
because that's the best possible way and
to make some huge Herculean effort to
try and do something just to be
different sometimes that's the wrong
answer
I get that hmm but consider it yeah yeah
a lot of times those the sweet like
certain industries are like this but
Ponemah but they're so used to doing it
a certain way because that's sort of
like what they learned yeah it's all
fresher it's almost like as an industry
they don't think of like what why
they're doing it that way well yeah
that's why that's why there's been so
many disruptors right in the last few
years
mm-hmm I mean you can look at any of
these disruptors companies that have
come out of nowhere that you know you
can look at the ride-sharing
applications
mm-hmm if you were a taxi driver you
were thinking okay how can we get more
dispatchers how can I hire more cars
these you know these ride-sharing people
said oh we're not gonna own any cars
yeah same with air B&B yeah right and
we're not gonna build a hotel we're
gonna use a random people's houses and
put you in there that's looking at it
from a completely different angle
seeing a problem and coming up with a
completely different solution if you
looked at a city and said oh wow
there's no rooms in that city there's no
hotel rooms in that city where am I
gonna put everyone okay well let's do
what everyone else does we'll build a
building and we'll put rooms in there
and we'll staff the building and we'll
put a restaurant that's what you do yeah
that's what's been done guess what
someone else looked the gun said you
know there's nowhere to stay in that
city but some people might have empty
rooms in their house let's see if we can
access those yes boom there you go yeah
I wonder how was that where the guy one
of the guys is like hey shoot I can't
find a hotel room when I go to San
Francisco and then the friend of like
hey just come stay with me you know and
then when he stayed with them he was
like you know next time you come if you
if you can't find a hotel room you can
always stay with yeah but I call yeah by
the way I'm coming up here I'm coming up
on you know my companies pay me come up
here
so I can get them you know they'll give
me money for the room so maybe I could
just pay you yeah oh cool we're kind of
we're kind of getting a little helpless
kickback company yeah cool and then the
next thing you know hey I've had other
cities have I know a guy down the road
he has a room that's really used so if
you have any co-workers or no and if you
know anybody I don't know that guy - ah
simple as that
yeah simple as that but it's looking at
it from a different angle so look at
things from a different angle then once
you come up you know fierce
determination fierce determination is
always good yeah that makes sense
they're a dichotomy - fierce
determination yes there is can you have
someone that's too fiercely determined
fiercely determined yes you can yeah yes
you can they don't know when to stop me
next the other aspect of urban terrain
are the spaces between buildings streets
alleys and other pathways are normal
routes for humans and therefore must be
suss must be must be suspected to be
under observation and possible enemy
firing lanes whenever possible take the
most difficult route from house to house
same thing we just talked about look for
a different path established and then
and there's obviously there's dichotomy
to that because if you're constantly
just taking the hard road all the time
you might not make any progress it is
also bad establish an advance a plan of
what to do in the event non-combatants
are found in urban zones and for marking
buildings that have been cleared it's
kind of crazy that they didn't have an
idea of how they're gonna mark buildings
that were cleared continuing make
absolutely sure that your Marines are
aware that while inside a building being
secured they are at risk from both
within and without always assume that
every room of every floor in each and
every house contains enemy soldiers
always move very quickly when moving in
front of windows or doors always know
where enemy positions may be in
buildings that are adjacent to yours as
in all marine operations watching
your buddies back watch your buddies
back and run as fast as possible in
traversing open ground can't let your
guard down
mmm can't let your guard down where do
you let your guard down me yeah can't
tell you it's it's probably a pretty
broad area 100% of my life time where
you feel like hey I need to get my guard
up this is probably an easier question
for you yeah you know you're not running
around hyper-paranoid Jack I am yeah
yeah what in life you mean or in jujitsu
what like everything yeah like I would
say I don't know it put it this way my
guards always up but it's only kind of I
think you know it's like a 25% up and if
what kind of fluctuates from moment to
moment
Lux rates up from like zero he stays at
25 sometimes it goes up to like 30 yeah
sometimes certain scenarios yeah check
multiple stories structures present an
even greater challenge than single story
buildings in medium-sized village or
town or small city that is dominated by
one two and three story buildings be
very particular about the taller
buildings which are naturally used by
the enemy as high ground if possible
make entry to taller multi-level
buildings via the roof and work
systematically and thoroughly downward
always look for the high ground so is
that sort of the the thing you know cuz
okay the high ground kind of seems
simple straightforward or whatever but
is there like a blueprint like a simple
blueprint for like I remember you told
me a story where your son was talking
with like a neighbor or something who
had I don't know if he went to Vietnam
or something like he was in he was in
the military whatever and you get and
they played like laser tag or something
and it's unlike whooped him because he
knew you liked something well yeah my
son knew some fundamental tactics it was
when he was younger so he wasn't really
up to speed yet he was like seven or six
but you know not up this we started you
know he was he was already through I
think
I think it was through level seven of my
tactical course yeah
he's probably on level seven what
tactical course I have like some
tactical lessons I run you know what I
mean that you run like as a father or as
a what like a chillán front has a
tactical course they wouldn't know I
have a tactical concepts that I teach do
you teach why because you need nothing
because you know that's just the
standard you know if you know certain
things you have to learn in order to be
tactically proficient and I've my son
have learned like I'd gone through seven
of the courses to understand the
tactical things and there was a friend
of my wife's friend came over he yes he
was prior marine actually he was active
duty marine and yes my son challenged
him to a laser talk tag competition and
yes my son was victorious three times in
a row and he just did simple fundamental
tactics and it wasn't even team sport it
was a one-on-one yeah so how do you
defeat someone one-on-one
well you maneuver very quickly you don't
fire from the same same position
multiple times you get the high ground
because you like he knew if you get onto
my garage roof which had access with a
ladder you're gonna be able to defend
that position very thoroughly and the
person that's below you because all you
have to do when you're on the garage
roof is dock and you're hidden it's it's
a parapet roof yeah so yeah if there's a
deck up there yeah there's a one access
point how are you gonna beat me you
don't have grenades with the layer of
laser grenades he's alive the high
ground
yeah I'm seven years old or six years
old I have the high ground I have a
laser weapon you're trying to attack me
you're gonna die yeah and then the next
round when you're trying to get up on
that thing
I'm not there anymore yeah I'm in the
alley way up the alley way up behind the
fence higher still higher still so the
high ground is kind of like the golden
good hmm
yeah interesting you know when the first
time I found out
the high ground is that is the spot to
be where when I watch the movie called
The Rock washout Sean Connery and where
the Navy SEALs come up you know they
gotta go to Alcatraz they come up
through the wherever the journey is like
this yeah and they get you know boom
they're sort of surprised by the I think
they're Marines
yeah the Terry they're mercenaries at
this point but nonetheless or Patriots
depend faith right exactly right yeah
and he was like hey your guys just
surrounded uh from an elevated position
yeah it's kind of like this is a no
brainer you know this kind of thing I
guess that's a thing yeah
and it is a thing you know huh and they
and they killed them all yeah except for
Nicolas Cage he didn't die that's that's
chemical agent by the way right VX gas
no that's what I was gonna say yeah but
but you know that was a real or you I
yeah let's face it surprised you didn't
just dive deep right into that I was
gonna like you know this little pearl
the little pearl balls there yeah
interesting back to the book the mission
assigned to marine forces during
operation away city was to remove enemy
forces that had captured major sections
of the ancient imperial capital of way
during the surprise NVA offensive that
was quickly dubbed the Tet Offensive due
to the historic listen closely
due to the historic aspect of many of
the buildings in a way the usage of
heavy weapons was significantly
restricted during the initial days of
fighting on both sides of the river as
friendly casualties mounted and as
initial estimates of the size of the
enemy force in waste city area was
significantly increased fire
restrictions were ultimately lifted so
they didn't want to damage these
historical buildings and so they said
hey don't don't use 50 Cal don't use
whatever whatever weapons they said they
couldn't use and then eventually when
the casualties got so bad they said okay
to go ahead and do what you got to do I
say rip the band-aid off right if you're
gonna go you go
if you're gonna go go don't play around
mm-hmm that's a good lesson America
learns over and over and over again if
you're gonna go to war go to win your
number one priority over everything else
should be to win and by the way if they
would have done that I guarantee this
city would have been a better shape at
the end because the enemy is gonna drag
this thing out and it's gonna take
longer you're gonna have to end up
destroying every single building that's
there yeah make sense they continue in
our respectful opinion our ability to
successfully complete the mission was
initially severely impacted by the rules
of engagement again and this is a lack
of trust up and down the chain of
command if I have to impose strict rules
of engagement on my people I haven't
trained them well enough I don't trust
them they don't trust me they don't
understand the strategic mission and we
have a real problem
continuing although it is understood
that mission and rules of engagement are
not the exclusive responsibility of
marine leadership at the platoon company
battalion or even regimental level it is
strongly recommended that every effort
is made at every level in the chain of
command to ensure that balance has been
achieved between the demands of the
mission and the effect of the rules of
engagement on the ability of the command
to perform the mission successfully yes
you do have to have balance but what you
really should have is trust an
understanding of the situation so that
people don't need to be constrained by
rules if I have if I have if my leaders
understand what I want them to do and
they understand the constraints and they
understand the mission and they
understand the impact they don't need
any rules at all they just need to get
told to go yeah it's a I think about
like certain laws where if if this is
going to be the law of the land that
this law applies to everybody same thing
with rules of engagement where they got
it because they kind of gotta apply to
everyone right in a certain yes so
that's why they wind up being so strict
or they can and
thinking about laws to where there's
certain groups or individuals that's
like man that law kind of shouldn't
apply to me cuz I know better you know
but we're like you know like the guy
who's like okay uncle I there's this red
light right this is or this stoplight
not quite where the crossroad of that
stoplight is a dirt road and on both if
you turn in the dirt dirt road either
direction there's a gate that's always
closed it's only click okay it's for
like cane trucks and stuff or it was I
don't know what it is now but and the
cane truck guys have the key to the gate
this big long it you can't even turn in
there but there's still a stoplight
right so it's never red because it only
turns green when the kid but everyone
swallowed be red and the Gator be closed
you know you know that sort of happens
and here's the thing you can see the
gates quote no truck is coming even if
the truck was coming like they got a
stop and open the gate whatever should
you stay at that red stop light or can
you just blow through the light you
would think any responsible adult should
have the authority or whatever to see
that and just go through the light right
but the rules got apply to everybody
that's the thing it has to apply to
everyone what about the new driver who's
like they can discern quite as well
we're a safe red light running situation
versus a not so safe red light running
situation and then there's a spectrum
you know so when these rules get put in
place
they gotta apply to everybody the lowest
common denominator person and
unfortunately these highest higher
denomination more people gotta apply to
them too because you know you can't just
go down the line and be like okay this
rule applies to you but kind of kinda
you know just maybe thirty percent this
rule applies to him hundred percent of
course and him to you 1 percent because
you're this elite dude so you can you
know yeah ultimate it's like you know
it's hard to do that especially when you
deal with like a bunch of people so
that's why that can be a pain and that
sometimes seems hey do you parently
that's been bothering you for quite some
well how long
you lived in America for the mainland
like think about like the court system
or like you know ya know well what we'll
skip put in place for sure because
people don't trust the subordinates that
have to follow the rule right you know
you tell your kids you're not allowed to
go in the yard because the pools out
there right what you're really saying is
I don't trust it you're not gonna go in
the pool or I don't trust that you're
you can swim well enough you're a good
leader you'll be like okay we get it we
need to work on this you understand the
dangers that's a little bit of a weird
thing to talk about because drowning the
pool for a little kid you obviously have
to err towards the side of safety that's
probably not the best example but if you
tell your kid no one's allowed to come
to ok I'm going on a trip Friday night
no one come over to the house those are
the rules right you know yeah if my kids
actually understood what I really meant
is like hey if you want have a couple
kids over that's cool don't get crazy
don't eat my food and weird to stay away
from the Molk no weirdos no you know if
they understood all that which actually
that's what my kids were no um hey got a
couple kids coming over it's all good
you know if they broke the trust then
things might be different then I have to
go and implement rules
yeah but on top of that you're - you're
talking about like your kids or like you
know in the military if you're dealing
with like one unit or one little group
of people but if the rules of engagement
or in your case like the rule of people
coming over what if what if it didn't
just apply to your kids what if it
applied to the whole block or the whole
town or whatever so it's like just to
keep everyone safe we gotta set this is
the standard which is why we don't want
communism yes because they just make the
holes that are up and blanket over every
well that's how laws aren't even here
you know like the gun laws consider the
gun laws first you're like hey we need
background check but the Guru's gotta
apply to everyone you know you can't
like discriminate kind of thing you they
have to apply to everybody so it's like
man well yeah that's the gun rules are a
perfect example because they don't trust
the the people everyone yeah certain
people yeah Oh everyone just can't have
a gun you have to get a background check
ok fair enough why but then it goes then
it continues see that's that's where
that's where you run into problems where
much debate about gun laws because
pretty much everyone says hey I get it
you should probably get some kind of a
background check before you get a
firearm
yeah everyone goes mmm okay I don't want
somebody that's been I don't want
somebody that's a felon or a violent
criminal to be able to get a gun cool I
agree with that the problem is where
does it stop and and then the problem on
top of that is because of the where does
it stop because of the slippery slope
thing the people that don't want any gun
laws they just say we don't want any
like every single you know well we think
we should that the background check
should be an extra three days yo yeah
and meanwhile on the other side people
are saying every single thing that they
can do to restrict firearms from being
had by anybody they try and move it
there yeah so both sides more just take
an extreme position and no one will
actually have a normal logical
conversation about what's going on yeah
it's just and even when you do man it in
yelling and screaming yes and that and
from the Pollard polarized positions
yeah and a lot of times even if you're
in that in the moment like you can step
back and see that when that happens when
people are just like hey you're just
defending your position just yeah just
kind of blindly or whatever you can see
that happen I'm not saying like it's so
terrible it's natural I get it but even
if you can have like a civilized
discussion it's still hard because it's
based on people yeah because like for me
I should absolutely be at be able to
have whatever guns I want yeah right
that's that's the way I feel I feel that
I should build and I yes you can check
my background you can see if I am a
felon or a violent criminal you can see
that I'm not okay you should be able to
be able to get whatever guns I want and
but there's some people that think hey
you know but as strongly as I feel about
that
as strong as I feel like I should be
able to want to get whatever guns I want
if someone says oh well then you agree
that everyone should be able to get
every gun they want no actually I don't
agree with that I think that there's
some people that don't need guns
I can say that I can say that without
without thinking without saying oh well
but Jocko believes in gun control for
everyone it's like no I just said what I
believed so the rules are about trust
and you have to figure out where the
trust lies with everyone by the way and
you have to figure out what the minimum
amount of trust is that you can overlay
on people everywhere everywhere and
that's where that's why governing a
giant country so hard yeah and depending
on where you live - cuz depending on
where you live you have different needs
yeah you have different like there's
some people that live yeah there's
different but depending on where you
live like if you live in a state where
there's predatory animals yeah and you
live out in the bush somewhere you're
damn right you need guns if you live in
a state where there's predatory animals
that are human beings that will break in
your house and kill you guess what you
also need to be able to protect your
family that's good to go
you know somebody asked me their day is
like is is it's actually Tim was
actually Tim Ferriss he was asking me if
pepper spray is good home defense I'm
like pepper spray is good home defense
against a person that isn't carrying a
weapon I said but if someone's breaking
into your house or coming to attack you
are they not going to have a weapon
dude are they following some kind of a
rules of engagement where they're I'm
going on a basic B&E tonight I'm only
gonna bring you know I'm only gonna
bring my my my pillow to hit people with
no your house to kill you or they're
breaking in your house just to assault
your family yeah well whatever the
breaking in your house - they shouldn't
be breaking in your house yeah and
they're probably gonna be able to defend
themselves because they don't want to
get caught so what do they do to defend
cells they got a knife or they got or
whatever they got a gun so pepper spray
great
the problem with pepper spray is you
don't you don't they're not following
rules of engagement you know rules of
engagement yeah that's a good question -
but like pepper spray why would you use
like think of a real scenario where you
would use pepper spray as a human girl I
get it cuz you have valuable goods
regardless of where you go you know you
can be at the post off you still got
those value
goods that that predators might want as
a girl but let's say okay I'm Tim
Ferriss or I'm you know me or whatever
why when would I use the preppers pepper
spray realistically I'm sure that I
think they're just asking that because
it's a legitimate question because if
someone says look I'm not really
comfortable with guns but if someone
wants comes into my house I wanna be
able defend myself I'm gonna get pepper
spray and they the the real quick answer
is like yeah okay cool yeah better than
it makes you go oh that kind of makes
sense right at least you got something
the reality is the person's coming in
your house it pepper spray is great as
long as they don't have a knife yeah as
long as they don't have a gun in which
case the pepper spray is doing you no
good yeah cuz you pepper spray me and I
have a knife I'm gonna grab a hold of
you I'm gonna I'm gonna cut your head
off right that's what's gonna happen in
a situation that you got to use a pepper
spray so like if someone's like
burglarizing you and you turn on the
light and they scatter you don't need
the pepper spray for that kind of
situation you know pepper spray is for
someone who like well yeah but you don't
know that they're gonna scatter yeah
just like you don't know if they have a
gun not yes yeah yeah and if you're
prowling around in someone's house
you're gonna be in a serious situation
yeah I think you should be you're gonna
get a real bad situation
yeah so peppers that's what we rules are
and rules of engagement so going back
trying to bring this back rules of
engagement that's exactly that's exactly
why rules of engagement can be tricky
but they shouldn't be if you train your
people well if the people understand
what the strategic mission if they
understand what the parameter you put
the parameter in there and they're loose
enough that people can maneuver inside
those parameters then occasionally they
gotta call you up and say hey I had to
break the rules and you say oh what
happened and they explain it to you okay
good call yeah yeah people need to
understand that mmm-hmm continuing on
urban combat is nearly always conducted
at very close quarters it is not
uncommon to have opposing forces
fighting from positions a few dozen
meters apart most of the fighting is
done from a distance between 50 and 500
meters due to this close in nature it is
critical to know where the enemy is and
how they are deployed again this is a
fantasy like knowing where the enemy is
and
they're deployed is really hard to do
even when you have even when you have
overhead coverage looking in the city
I'll - I'll give you an example
I was watching my guys out on a mission
I was watching on a UAV feed so we're
watching we're watching and looking for
enemy and all of a sudden we see weird
activity there's a vehicle the vehicle
stops the vehicle kind of moves a little
bit stops again guys get out they look
around open up the trunk and now we're
totally focused like oh these guys are
getting ready to attack open up the
trunk and as they're starting to pull
stuff out of the trunk my guys get hit
from a different spot that we weren't
looking because you can't see everything
especially in a city because think of it
with buildings as soon as you go off
angle a little bit you can't see the
street anymore because it's it's down in
the building so we actually have totally
focused on this one thing and
maneuvering the the air asset to look at
these people in a car hmm and as as
there as we're monitoring these guys
these suspected enemy personnel also my
guys get shot at from somewhere else and
we completely miss it mm-hmm and we
continue to watch these guys and they
pull out a jack and a tire and they lift
up the car and they change the tire and
they leave like it's just normal but it
looked very suspect so to think that
you're ever gonna know where the enemy
is and how they're deployed is very very
challenging at best you do the best it
doesn't mean you don't try you
definitely try but you you don't get all
that information you just don't get it
hey those UAVs how how high are those
depends on the UAV so like can you can
they see them like can people see them
where are they depends on the UAV yeah
and like I'm not I don't know what the
classification of all that stuff is so
I'm not talking about it good I don't
know what the I just know that they go
different heights I'll leave it at that
yeah well cuz on the internet you can
see those you know those videos every
once in a while
yeah he'll just have them yeah yeah and
it's like dang those guys don't even see
that or you know I don't know if they do
or don't or good optics - yeah like real
good optics I mean just imagine you know
the optics that we have in the civilian
sector
even those aren't good enough to be
pretty amazing yes sir so I'm talking
about knowing where the enemy is this
lesson was learned the hard way during
the initial stages the battle inside the
Citadel during the first two major
clashes between marine and NVA forces on
the morning of 13 February 1968 the
enemy surprised us and wreaked
significant damages very quickly this is
because we weren't exactly sure where
they were although the the arvin which
the South Vietnamese Army had been in
several major battles inside the Citadel
I don't recall receiving any
intelligence attributed attributed to
them regarding the enemy's exact
location further to my knowledge no
marine recon unit was sent to check out
the situation before it's acting on the
morning the 13th so that's rough and
I'll tell you one thing that from my
mind where's the enemy the enemy's
everywhere
mmm that you have to approach things as
if the enemy can be anywhere and the
only way you can know that they're not
where they're not everywhere is when you
take something down and you secure it
that's when you know not there then you
move on mmm we recommend that all
intelligence assets recon units and
surveillance devices that can be made
available are deployed in a significant
effort to fix the exact location of
enemy soldiers and units again this is
you can see where this is coming out of
this for these guys they must have been
completely outflanked all the time where
they were thinking where is the enemy we
need to know where the enemy is and is
really hard to know that the enemy
combatant who knows where his enemy is
hiding experiences this experience as a
decided advantage in surprise and the
deployment of firepower of course now
again this doesn't look like I've seen
it's hard that definitely doesn't mean
you made again it doesn't mean you don't
put up UAV so you can see maneuver
doesn't mean you don't gather
intelligence doesn't mean people
shouldn't report back and explain where
they think the enemy is so we at least
have an estimate mm-hmm continuing the
combat urban combat tactics the tragedy
of urban conflict is that the
battlefield for each firefight is a
neighborhood each objective taken is
someone's home or a school or Church or
some other structure that has value and
full and more or less significant
meaning to its inhabitants
considering the possibilities it is not
difficult to imagine tank battles across
mall parking lots
mortar fire hitting a church a hospital
or community center heavy small-arms
fire fights between homes and artillery
barrage on a schoolyard while these
images may be grist for the mills of
Hollywood when we think about them in
relevance to our homes and our
neighborhood schools and churches the
tragedy is somehow increased however it
is our collective belief that the life
of one marine is more precious than 10
100 homes schools churches shrines
shopping malls or any other building
known to man therefore all efforts
should be made using any and all weapon
tree available to stun the enemy and
support marine advances through the use
of supporting arms and without regard to
damage to buildings so clearly the whole
idea that this started off with of the
rules of engagement that were
restricting heavy firepower because the
historical nature of the city a if you
don't want historical buildings
destroyed don't have a war and if you
think we should save a building and
that's gonna cost the life of one of our
brothers not happening continuing at the
same time the use of heavy weapon tree
in urban combat is an assuredly
two-edged sword as our many assets in
modern warfare rubble can be nearly as
effective as a building for protecting
enemy firing positions further artillery
and other flat trajectory weapons may be
somewhat restricted by the height of
buildings and their distance from each
other in many cases mortars although
smaller in caliber were superior because
of their higher trajectory so
interestingly indirect fire indirect
fire taking the indirect approach is
often better than the flat trajectory
I'm gonna shoot through your front door
no we're gonna lob in some rounds on you
so so we think about that when we're
dealing with people punching them in the
face is not as good
is coming from an indirect position
where they don't quite see where it's
coming from
but it still gives him a little bit back
and the it's even to the point where he
says the even though they're smaller in
calibre so even though somebody does
something that you want to straighten
them out on when you hit him in the face
we know what the reaction is they get
defensive all ethics when we come from
from a flank indirect fire it's smaller
caliber it's not even as it's doesn't it
is hard just more effective indirect
fire all day long
continuing supporting arms supporting
arms the most effective are most
effective prior to danger close to
minimize the potential of friendly
casualties and maximize preparatory
fires to support the Infantry's attack
during Operation wasted II the most
effective indirect fire during
danger-close was from an eight-inch gun
we recommend that the supporting axis of
fire be perpendicular as well as
parallel finally in the event as in the
case of operation Way city that due to
political considerations that proper
preparatory fires would not be allowed
that a variety of artillery fires such
as smoke delayed fuses high-angle can be
incorporated with the Infantry's attack
combined arms training for urban combat
is critical its cover and move that's
what supporting arms do they lay down
cover so you can maneuver it other
advantages of preparatory fire include
the destruction of the camouflage of
enemy positions the psychological shock
factor against enemy troops and the fact
that heavy weapons can create new
avenues of attack and egress for armored
vehicles pretty straightforward one of
the most effective aspects of supporting
arms during the battle of way where the
killer teams that evolved the m48 tank
and the N and Antos and the Antos is
like a it's it's actually a pretty crazy
looking machine it's got 160 106
millimeter like cannons on it and it's
got six of them and they're kind of like
sticky now and it's a light armored
vehicle so it's like a tank anti-tank
vehicle but um Antos will pair up and
maneuver together as a team this would
allow either the tank or
on toast to maneuver into a good fire
position where while the other covered
cover move thank you further the
devastating firepower put out by the 90
millimeter tank cannon and the six 106
is of the Antos turned out to be
extremely beneficial because their
capabilities to deliver pinpoint of
firepower armored vehicles can provide
many benefits to the infantry engaged in
urban combat as they provide some cover
from enemy small-arms fire
however armored vehicles can also become
rocket magnets producing casualties for
infantry troops in close proximity the
enemy is gonna see that target yeah and
they're gonna like it
yeah and these advantages to having that
power but there's also disadvantage so
you have to always weigh those things
out as a leader you have to pay
attention to those things as a leader
you have to think of every advantage
that you have there's gonna be some
negative to it there's gonna be some
disadvantage when you bring into vintage
the table there's gonna be some
disadvantage and jujitsu right if you're
gonna be super flexible you're not that
strong ya ever gonna be super stronger
not that flexible your cardio doesn't
last very long right so there's gonna be
advantages and disadvantages that come
with each asset that you have yeah so
you have to think you're gonna go for
full ox that's cool you're giving up
position mm-hmm there's all kinds of
things you have to weigh this out and as
leader you have to look at don't get
don't get wrapped around the positives
of something right just just the
positives there's not just positives for
for really anything yeah there's nothing
that's just straight positives across
the board I guess right yeah you're sure
we could think of something yeah and I'm
sure you could continue other than
instances of harrassment and
interdiction fires buildings that are
hit by heavy weapons should be attacked
immediately this is good
buildings that are hit by heavy weapons
should be attacked immediately
don't hesitate you catch people
off-guard don't hesitate don't hesitate
this happens this happens in in
everything we we get a good a good
position or something and advantageous
happens and we hesitate yeah instead of
any advantage we go
here well and then then we then we let
it go it happens in business too we get
to a situation oh we finally get the we
finally get our competitor to make a
mistake or we get an advantage position
and we celebrate instead of just
finishing the job yeah which is a big
bad thing do ya remember that when
calling in fire missions you can request
splash so your friendly troops have time
to take cover immediately prior to
impact these guys were calling bombs
right on top of them a lot mm-hmm
in daytime operations the use of
covering smoke is often helpful when
Marines must attack across open areas as
was learned during Operation Way city
even with proper support of heavy
weapons which was ultimately provided to
the Marines we faced hardcore North
Vietnamese Army troops who fought from
prepared positions moved to secondary
positions fought again and finally very
reluctantly died in the capture of each
room each for each rooftop each building
each Street it was ultimately the marine
riflemen who won the battle it's as a
leader as a leader do you always have to
remember that line right there in the
capture of each room each for each
rooftop each building each street it was
ultimately the marine riflemen who won
the battle as a leader if you think that
all you need to do is make a good
decision and then you're gonna win
you're wrong the folks on the front line
have to truly understand what is
happening and they're the ones are gonna
carry the day and you can come up with a
best battle plan ever you could come up
with a best strategic business plan ever
and if you don't have folks that are
engaged and willing and are gonna take
the fight to the enemy and are gonna win
that that foothold they're gonna enter
that room they're gonna go out and sell
into whatever industry you're trying to
get into if you don't have people that
you trust that are trained that are
ready that are prepared
if you don't have them best paddle
battle plan in the world isn't gonna
work mmm it's critical for infantry
units to know both the capabilities as
well as the limitations of supporting
arms know your limitations right this is
again there's positives and there's
negatives another aspect of supporting
arms limitations has to do with
helicopter support urban terrain is not
very forgiving to helicopters that may
be forced to make an emergency landing
helicopter pilots might be reluctant to
fly over urban terrain know these things
one very tragic aspect of using
supporting arms in urban combat is that
the likelihood of civilian casualties is
very high in at least two situations
that we are aware of the NVA used
civilians as screens for their infantry
troops and fire missions were of
necessity called in on those positions
so no expect pre discuss these things
let your troops understand put them in
roleplay scenarios where they have to
make a decision on what's happening it's
better to think through it 20 times and
make 20 mistakes while we're doing some
kind of a roleplay scenario than it is
to have to be making that decision for
the first time when you're on the
battlefield you can't discuss you can't
debrief yeah not to mention the stress
that's gonna yeah yeah absolutely use of
chemical weapons during one-fives battle
inside the Citadel fortress which was
kicked off on 13 February 1968 the
battalion progressed a total of four
blocks along our Avenue of attack and
had secured a total of 16 city blocks
within our assigned area of operations
after nearly two weeks of heavy street
fighting and after suffering nearly 50%
casualties at the hands of a
well-prepared determined force of NVA
soldiers a force that finally estimated
that was finally estimated to be nearly
11,000 strong in Hawaii
in the wasted e area of operations On
February 25th 1968 Marines from Charlie
Company shot off 3e8 gas launchers
carrying about 40 CS gas grenades toward
the enemy's last-known position the next
morning one-five took control of the
remaining 12 city blocks in about three
hours without a single casualty because
the NVA was not equipped to deal with
tear gas attack and was forced to
withdraw so we're going from 50%
casualties to zero taking a different
approach utilizing weapons that no one
was used to utilizing the enemy who had
never had not seen they even have gas
masks they just had to get out of there
and that ei gas lock launcher it's like
a suitcase looking thing and it's got
eight tubes that have eight rounds out
eating them mm-hmm and it fires him like
five seconds apart so we're talking a
lot of gas hmm especially they shot off
three of them you don't want none of
that no one can ever be certain that the
use of chemical weapons would have made
a difference in the initial stages of
the battle but many of the veterans of
that battle have often wondered what
might have happened if the e eights had
been deployed in the early stages of the
battle we recommend the judicious use of
chemical weapons such as tear gas etc
for combat operations administration
planning and preparation the inherent
complexities of urban combat are such
that special attention needs to be paid
toward planning and preparations
training training training practice
makes perfect a coordinated marine
attack on an enemy held position in a
town or city can be equated to an
intricate opera or Broadway production
although the stakes are a bit higher
entry techniques room search and
clearing techniques voice commands
indicating movement or progress fire
discipline the use of grenades rocket
supporting fires communications all of
these must be rehearsed and improved
until they are second nature
second nature I was talking to you the
other day
mm-hmm you were saying something about
my guillotine choke yeah that it was
there quickly yes yeah and I was saying
its second its I should have said it's
second nature because what I did tell
you is sometimes I become aware like
we'll be rolling and all of a sudden
I'll be like oh I've got a guillotine
right now yeah I didn't even this way
just showed up there yeah zero thought
whatsoever yeah yeah that's how you need
to be yeah if I have to think about
putting a guillotine on someone then
that means they have time to think about
defending right if I didn't even think
about it it just happened to sort of
yeah and and didn't not to split hairs
it's less about the guillotine
specifically it's just about your head
like what do you call a head control it
you know you know you get that chin
strap oh it's that where that just
arrives and then sure it'll become a
guillotine for sure more cobra or one of
these other treacherous moves that you
like to implement sometimes it time yeah
but yeah it's like your head well I feel
like I feel like it's second nature for
my head to just land in there that's
what it feels like for sure but
obviously it's your thing oh no but
that's the way we want to Train that's
the way we're gonna train and I would
say I'll add to this that what we want
to Train is we want to train for chaos
we want to train for mayhem we want to
train for the enemy to do things we're
not expecting that's what we want to
train for because when you train for
things that the enemies not exceed
you're not expecting the enemy do you
actually get good at reacting to it you
know you can get good at at scrambling
yeah in jujitsu yeah you can get good at
ending up in positions that are
beneficial the through no conscious
thought but because you've scrambled
enough that now you just know what
you're looking for these little these
little things are gonna happen I'm gonna
get the underhook I'm gonna get my hips
in the right spot I'm gonna move my head
over here yeah that's what we want to do
yeah yeah like the old almost cliche
saying to like get comfortable being
uncomfortable the thing
it's like yeah he train yourself to be
uncomfortable or to be trained in being
uncomfortable you can just deal better
but I'm trying to get something I'm
trying to reach a different point here
my point is this if I let's say let's
say here's there's a through Z
situations I can put you in mm-hmm and
they're all different if I train you for
a and B all the time when I throw a fad
you you're lost
yeah if I throw Q at you you're you're
lost yeah if I train you so I get you
good at a and B but then I start
training you at D I start throwing you
at F I start throwing you at M you will
start to realize that even in these
disparate scenarios there are some
commonalities and there are some base
positions that you can go to that will
allow you the time to assess and make
decisions so you can hit you can get
good at chaos that's what I'm saying you
can get good at chaos yeah yeah you can
get good at it you can say oh when I see
things happening that I don't understand
here's what I need to do I need to find
a good covered position
hopefully elevated where I can look
around I need to figure out where my
troops are I need to do it very quickly
I need to identify a prominent terrain
feature that I can move all of us to in
a rapid manner so that I can get control
the situation right there now with those
things that I just said hey I'm gonna
get in a position where I can look
around I'm gonna look for a I'm gonna
try and figure out where my people I'm
gonna look for a prominent terrain
feature that I can utilize as a
stronghold guess what I just solved for
just about any scenario that unfolds
that I don't understand I have a plan I
have a plan that I can actually
implement against any situation think
about that so oh if I get a contact
front
I have a plan oh we start getting acog
shot up from the front and we're in
open ground I have a plan it's a
standard operating procedure
oh I start getting shot at from the
front and we're in closed terrain I have
a plant there's a specific immediate
action drill we're gonna perform oh wait
a second I'm getting shot at I'm not
sure where it is I hear screaming I know
that we're getting hit from multiple
locations what do I need to do I have an
immediate action for that too
mmm I'm gonna find cover I'm gonna look
around I'm gonna try and figure out
where my troops are and I'm gonna look
for a prominent terrain feature that we
can move towards yeah there now of a
sudden the chaos isn't really chaos
right now all the sudden I have a plan
yes connect and I can actually apply
that plan to almost any scenario yeah so
the more that you train people for
things that they don't expect and don't
understand the better they will get it
dealing with those things yeah and
that's very positive yeah moving on
further all plans must be communicated
and rehearsed at each level of command
from the fire team to the company and
above it sounds like these guys did not
have a good decentralized command in
terms of actually knowing what the
overall plan was it sounds like the fire
teams were there even the platoon and
fire team levels were a little bit lost
at points in particular platoon
commanders platoon sergeants and squad
leaders and fireteam leaders must be
aware of each man's assignment this
should include who goes into a structure
first who covers cover move nowadays
because we've done it in the US
military's done so much urban combat in
the last what has it been 17 years every
military unit in the US military they
can take down a structure and they do it
well and they do it off of standard
operating procedures not off of a
specific plan of who goes where
continued on hand and arm signals as
well as vocal commands should be
established and practiced and the last
section is called command and control in
full-scale urban conflict especially in
situations where enemy dispositions are
not well known initial contact with the
enemy can be a unexpected be at very
close range and see massively
devastating command and control the
basic Marines connection to his
leadership can disappear in the blink of
an eye during Operation Way city charlie
won five lost all of its officers except
for two sergeants became platoon
commanders PFCs were squad leaders in
urban combat it would not be at all
surprising to find PFCs as platoon
commanders given the potentially high
casualty rates the critical factor for
unit survival in these situations is
that units ability to immediately
determine the enemy's position and to
return a high volume of sustained fire
on those positions allowing
maneuverability despite the situation
with the chain of command
so two critical things there cover and
move is one and decentralized commanders
- that's what they're talking about you
need to be able to put down high a heavy
volume of sustain fire on positions so
that you can maneuver and and at the
same time you need to be able to do that
regardless of the situation with the
chain of command decentralized command
during the first day of one-fives
involvement in operation way City Alpha
Company lost its CEO its XO and much of
the company CP group of necessity alpha
was pulled back to the battalion rear
for reorganization loss of a few leaders
effectively eliminated an entire company
this also delayed the battalions attack
blunting of our initiatives you're gonna
have a plan if people go down who's
taken over that's got to be that's got
to be ready
the individual Marine who is under heavy
enemy fire from very close range who may
now be cut off from his team and/or
squad leader needs to have been
thoroughly informed of communications
codes lines of departures lines of
stoppage friendly unit dispositions and
the ability to call in supporting fires
and conduct contingency plans what does
that mean
that means the troops need to understand
what is happening in short in urban
conflict situations command and control
needs to be understood at every level
down to the basic Marine based on our
experiences during operation away city
expect the unexpected expect chaos and
plan for all possibilities and it's
signed Scott Nelson first lieutenant
commanding officer Charlie 1:5 Nick war
second lieutenant platoon commander
Charlie 1:5 Travis Kurd second
lieutenant Artillery forward observer
attached to Charlie 1:5 and John Mullen
Staff Sergeant platoon sergeant Charlie
1:5 Nick war is his name W arr
pretty stoked to be born with that war
was he's in the Marine Corps what you
mean my name is actually war yep so yeah
and and to hear from these guys and and
this is this this document which is now
well it's 50 years old 1968 and there's
still lessons learned in this that apply
to really apply to everything apply to
life apply to urban combat apply to
business apply to leadership so there
you have it and of course when we see
the way broadly we can recognize it more
we can see it in more things and it
makes us more effective leaders
regardless of the battlefield that we're
on so Reed and appreciate the lessons of
the past and echo mm-hmm speaking of the
way I know I know jujitsu is sort of
beneficial it's sort of helpful in
allowing us to understand the way more
clearly and perhaps even more broadly I
don't know if you have any
recommendations of how we can sort of
get in the game yeah and stay in the
game yeah it's funny you mentioned Jitsu
is like a way to recognize things like
its soul it's such a metaphor even to
use the word metaphor seems like it's
like detach it like it is life in so
many ways like all even this thing that
I'm listening to you yeah Reid I'm like
oh yeah just every single one out I just
don't want to bore everyone with okay
more jujitsu stuff well I said of that
on the judo podcast that we did I was
talking about the fact that I I have to
give credit some credit to jujitsu for
sort of revealing to me the thread that
tied all these things together us JP was
in town sure and we were rolling jujitsu
yesterday and I was thinking as
like well actually when we were done I
was thinking man when we were in Ramadi
12 years ago mm-hmm I was a black belt
in jujitsu like I like it was beneficial
for me then to have been a black belt in
jujitsu not because I wasn't going out
and grappling against the enemy but I
had already started to connect some of
these dots yeah and it's very very
helpful in life yeah it's also helpful
because it is a physical representation
that you can feel and you can see yeah
it's not a theory
yeah there's theory behind it but it's
not a theory it's happening to you and
therefore when it happens to you you
have something physical something
concrete something that you actually
experienced on a physical level and if
you and that allows you to understand it
metaphorically better mm-hmm yeah like
when you get caught when someone's
trying to choke you then pull them they
unlock you and you just got flanked yes
that just happened to you it's not
metaphorical right you you truly
understand what it feels like to get
flanked yeah if I explain to you hey
when I'm telling you this thing over
here and then I come at you from another
angle you understand it you're you're
just starting to grasp the concept but
it didn't happen to you
mm but when I'm trying to choke you and
you go for the defense and then boom you
get arm locked and you didn't see it
coming at all you feel a flank you feel
the effectiveness all right in real time
in real time yeah and that's why it's
very beneficial yeah to train some of
that jiu-jitsu oh yeah feel experience
the laws of combat mm-hmm feel them yeah
you'll have a better comprehension of
them yeah
and that's not like a profound level to
like that's like that's good if you can
keep that in mind and then you can go on
the other side of the spectrum where
it's like
see you just fighting with your friends
with no consequence you know where I
think a lot of time I mean like if
meaning if you go hey let's go train
right now
what we're gonna do when you say let's
go train sure we might go over some oh
we're fighting but without real concert
yes we don't lose friendship we don't
get injured we don't get you know
arrests all that stuff they but we get
to like fight you know I don't that's
also good yeah
so and here's the thing like so here's a
thing like some people in I think we
most people like we like fighting but we
don't wanna like fight people like I
don't want to fight everyone you know
well because then you can get arrested
well sir most people like I said we
don't just fight you know because
there's all kinds of different reasons
or whatever but when you can just when
you have the opportunity to to fight
someone with no consequence just to see
how it would go yeah you know like you
peez
you know these huge huge men you know
guys who are like seven feet tall four
hundred pound just huge and strong man
and stuff like that you don't want to
necessarily fight them but you're like
what that would be like one role with
them to fight with that guy you know
when you did you did see you get that
you get that opportunity straight up you
want to you want to try fight eat this I
wonder how many people out there
wondering I wonder would be to fight job
go mmm just say I would beat him up not
to say I wouldn't but I wonder how it
would be that well a lot of people show
up at the gym oh yeah oh and that's
exactly why I not funny point funny
thing is it doesn't matter if they're
white belts or black belts yeah they
still like yeah see what up see how they
that experience is you know usually
smiling yeah slowly and really when it
comes down to it unless you're trying to
hurt someone you know and there's a
bunch of different ways to hurt someone
if you want to hurt them because you
don't like gum or you think they should
you know they'd either all this stuff
it's not about that it can be about that
for sure but that's not ultimately what
it is it's more about like I wonder I
wonder how it'd be to fight that person
and then when you start to learn more
and more and more you just you really
just enjoy that activity like it's a
fight like right now if I wanted to if
you have the time or whatever I mean you
we can go fight right now yeah and it'd
be like in a good safe way you know wrap
to something but you see I'm saying no
that's the way to do it anyway okay all
right back to the path that's the path
in appropriate part of the path by the
way yeah you wouldn't be you without
jiu-jitsu I wouldn't you wouldn't even
be like happen especially if you knew I
wouldn't be happy at all you know
especially if I knew but on top of that
I wouldn't have connected things that I
met jiu-jitsu connected for me yeah
there's something else I would not be
Who I am no I'm gonna straight-up say
yes I would not be Who I am without
jiu-jitsu yeah and you wouldn't be who
you would not be on this podcast without
jiu-jitsu no I couldn't even talk to you
I mean it's a stretch anyway but without
jiu-jitsu at least there's something
right without that if you talking about
TV shows and not be like yeah I'd be
like muting your microphone or something
yeah let's see so dude it's a it's a
lifesaver same same yeah get you into
all kind of different things but yeah
you know and even if you're trying to
like it stay on the path okay I'm
dragging it I dig it man but it's
important when you're when you're trying
to get on the past stay on the path beat
be on the path it's only fitting for
real it's only fitting okay let's say
okay let's say you have weapons training
oh sweet let's say you can drive a car
really well cool you can hunt you can
you're capable you can you know all this
stuff right but if you're stripped away
of like your tools
oh then one you know it's man on man
yeah just don't have the digits and this
is yeah and this is more of just a real
general like way to look at it so it's
like you ever watch men in black yes
that wonder I can't really remember to
get about it this might not even be the
the movie but it's it's a movie with one
of the it's like this big rope creature
right and then they
it's just a suit and in the inside
there's just this little worm type
person thing you know that kind of you
know well so you're saying if I didn't
do jiu-jitsu I would just be like a
little worm yeah yeah yeah the big you
know strong guy or whatever but then
like if all your tools were taken away
what are you left with kind of thing
isn't it weird when you meet people that
are that like they do they're like big
you know maybe even they're strong maybe
even they are aggressive you know but
they they don't have because I don't
have a skill they don't have the skill
right that's kind of a bummer
that's essentially here's this here's
the situation that people might be
listening and think okay well let's say
you're in the situation when you don't
have the skill well you have two options
option one is the easy path which is I'm
just never gonna get that skill never to
go near jiu-jitsu I'm never gonna get in
a confrontation with anybody because I
don't want to be proven to myself that
I'm a worm inside of a suit or you can
take the hard path which is even though
I'm 37 years old
mm-hmm I'm bummed that I missed out on
the BART Pope you know I took me a while
but you know what I'm gonna go figure
this out yeah I'm gonna go at least
learn some of it I'm gonna at least
learn some of it you know I would take
that oh yeah even though I know it's
hard mm-hmm because people you know when
you're when you get older you don't want
to try something new right even though
it's proven that learning something new
is completely beneficial for your mental
and physical health yeah yeah and I see
in that yeah it's not all like
pleasurable roses and stuff no no did
you there's some there's some struggle
in there brah but tell me about it
there's there's there I had a minister I
was I was in turtle position Dean
Lister's the shoulders healing back up I
was in turtle position mount and side
control for 22 minutes the other day and
that's a struggle and also he was
pushing my face into the mat and saying
what color is the mat
yeah see like I see what I'm saying well
what's that fun that the answer's no no
that's high-level struggle yeah because
the typical person you're going to do
that's not gonna happen to you
so like that's like the struggle that's
going to get someone that has a personal
vendetta on your existence yeah he has
on mine yeah yeah I think you're the see
default kill Joe does indeed yeah
factually nonetheless alright there's
gonna be some struggle in there you get
it buddy jump in there just like
everything when you learn golf there's
gonna be a struggle no you're gonna miss
that hole sometimes right no different
kinda struggle yeah yeah but on a
profound fundamental level it's all the
same struggle nonetheless you're gonna
meet Aggie and when you get your Yi
you're gonna go to origin mein kampf get
an origin key it's the best kind made in
America from the cotton grown in America
loomed or we've woven woven in America
assembled sewn stitched presented
enjoyed it utilized utilized cinema in
America actually can be utilized
wherever but on the last I mean in
America and they are factually now not
my opinion
sounds like an opinion but it's
factually they're factually the best
firm in the world yeah what's cool is
the geese are awesome but there's a
problem
what's the problem the problem is you
can't wear Aggie to the store no key to
the restaurant no not really
and yet you wear the origin pants and
you think man I wouldn't mind you know
they had a pocket I would roll out right
you know especially if you get the black
ones yes you know like it's not it's not
crazy to think hey maybe I'll just kind
of roll out to the store or maybe go
take my wife out for dinner
no yeah hey buddy that's okay cuz guess
what we got now denim origin jeans do
you get yeah yeah so those are common
yeah they're not quite out yet but I got
mine yeah I don't mind you know texting
Pete no I don't want to bother you know
Pete's
he's busy man he does a lot you know
what I don't want to her my personal
interests start to create roadblock or
speed bumps penis hole
thank but I do want those jeans though
that's a thing so I got a balance that
little dichotomy my personal interest in
the interests of Pete in this discourse
nonetheless I will have them we will
happen when do they come out then doctor
in the process of coming out right now
yeah have the material we are cutting
the material now we're so in the
material yes interesting because I don't
really get excited about jeans or I
don't get it like new jeans coming out
or the new iPhone car I don't get
excited about that kind stuff but for
some reason I'm kinda excited let me
tell you why I'm a little bit excited
about it hmm
because of this jeans are American right
jeans represent America let's face it if
you wanted to draw a stereotypical
American human they'd be wearing a pair
of jeans yeah here's the problem jeans
were made in America jeans were invented
America jeans became famous in America
and then we sold our soul and put them
overseas let him get manufactured
overseas something that shouldn't have
happened and so to bring it back to
America does that feel good indeed yes
it does yeah man make sense I dig it
bring back the soul other clothes
they're t-shirts and stuff from origin
if you you can get even if you don't
want jeans you'd get joggers right now
yeah man if you're quite comfy
supplements to join warfare krill oil
discipline discipline go discipline go
so when I work sometimes I have to work
four to three straight hours without any
interruptions oh yeah yeah you see I'm
saying so I would be drinking discipline
and all of a sudden I'm an hour and 40
minutes in and guess what I gotta hit
the head the restroom break yeah so
that's why we made discipline go this
moral is just a pill it's called the
capsule caps well yeah it's got the it's
got the goodness in it and we also have
coming the discipline going a can yeah
yeah that's like this you had it yet yes
and that's that is you have everyone
where like where was I
give you one in New York when we were
did the New York yeah I had one before
that they sent me so yes good I got it I
got more coming today hopefully they'll
be here but yeah so that'll be coming of
course we got milk which apparently dr.
Luke hates mint chocolate chip
passionately and yet heard him going off
the other day look why would you want
anything that tastes like toothpaste
miss toothpaste yeah so we have a little
disagreement we'll have to settle that
one on the map but he's just going with
peanut butter or vanilla gorilla or
something good and don't forget about
the war your kid milk no kidding yeah it
tastes like strawberry Nestle's
strawberry Quik that's what it tastes
like
yeah can I say that is that legal yes
okay whether it's legal or not I can say
it I did say it and it's tastes exactly
like and I'm using that exactly like
there's strawberry Nestle's Quik but it
has no sugar it's got awesome protein
and it will make your kid into the next
you're about to say something illegal
right now the next squared away after I
say you very smart yes I was gonna name
names but so that's all remain calm yeah
props to all my people all my people up
at origin that are working every day
someone cotton stitching moving shipping
and make pretty much getting after it
yep big time also we have a store it's
called Jocko store you know stuff a
little bit more formulated for
representing the path itself you know a
little bit skewed but some good stuff on
there some new stuff on there too by the
way
oh really yeah they the traveler travel
mugs okay kind of new goodness I'm
putting a hoodie up there so black on
black
hmm I like the subtle have okay oh yes
is it legit heavy legit heavy legit like
it's the head is it a heaviest heaviest
one in existence I'm sorry to say no but
there has me one that you've ever made
yes okay it's hella it's I want
noticeably heavier
than the original yeah it's black on
black all right you got it to home
nonetheless good stuff on their rash
guards on there too for jiu-jitsu for
jiu-jitsu representing the path big-time
on now and also you can do other stuff
with rash guards as well but yeah some
good stuff on there if you want to
represent support stay on the path
that's where you go chuckles door comm
here's the thing about getting new stuff
to and this is this is where this is
where six-year-old echo brain comes out
yeah and you're a dog but it still
applies it's still fine and if this
dawns on me from time to time especially
when it hits me when you get like a new
thing right I've talked about this
before when you get a new graph you are
six years old brah don't leave me back
to you life you know what I think I
think you think the same thing I think
you feel the same way you won't
necessarily admit it specially not to me
but I think you I think you feel the
same way yeah okay if you got a negative
something that that excites me to get
new oh you keep doing what you're doing
I'll think of something arere well think
surfboard think whatever we have unless
there you go so if you get a new rash
guard a new gay even new socks sometimes
new shoes I've gotten new socks it's
like eighteen to forty three I get the
socks from on it for me I get fired up
nonetheless you get something you get a
rash guard this is good after if you
don't have one already you will be
looking forward to going to jiu-jitsu
that much more and that's the good thing
about like these things that are all the
pounds it's hundred percent correct try
it try actually I would say for anyone
who has like you know shirt or whatever
they felt it oh that's what that's I
predict no III understand what you're
saying and it actually is true when
people when you get that you know that's
the classic the classic scene from
literature sure when is the I think it's
like the dawning of the uniform of them
of the warrior yeah yeah when they do in
movies to the collage they know the the
hero is putting his boots on and then
he's putting his web gear on and even
just when people see you know the
superheroes secret thing opens up in all
this
later it's all fired up yes or like the
the old vet that's going to that chest
in his or like in in Mikey the Dragons
you know when he's open opening up the
chest and filled with war gear yeah yeah
you know i yeah because they understand
yeah exactly
alright there we go so same deal anyway
Jaakko store calm you're gonna represent
on the path get fired up about stuff
there you go see something like grab
something also chuck awake tea we're
still doing that i'm still doing that
big time because that was never a tea
person and what I mean I'm saying that's
that's saying something because I was
never a tea person but guess what look
at me tea person now what kind of I only
drink this tea but you know I'm into it
you're a jock a white tea person
apparently big tonight how does that
deadlift huge eighty one hundred pounds
actually particular in it hey subscribe
to the podcast if you haven't iTunes
Google Play stitcher leave reviews so I
can read them yeah if you want if you
want if you don't want the don't what
also warrior kid podcasts subscribe to
that I was on a podcast yesterday and
they asked me to say subscribe to their
podcast yeah and I said I don't even ask
people to subscribe to my podcast and I
was like well actually I got a new and
now I just did yeah maybe it's you know
yeah actually you and I had this
discussion many times I was like why do
we need to do you like what people need
to subscribe maybe they haven't
subscribed I mean we're a hundred and 60
to the podcast deep that's got to be for
500 hours of listening I don't think
someone hit subscribed yet well I agree
with you fully so we can we cut this out
now week yeah
you wrote this by the way but yeah of
course we can well this is this is a
carryover yes
carryover oh yes look it's us doing what
we talked about before earlier today
about doing things like because it's
that's just how you know we gotta think
gotta think why do we want to waste five
seconds of someone's time telling them
you know it just sounds kind of like
what is it like what we called redundant
or something it's kind of like you think
everyone do you think anyone ever
got to this point three hours deep into
the podcast in you or I said and
subscribing up and they reach down to
they're like yes oh yeah oh I do that
yeah yeah you're right let me tell you
what you might forget you might forget
to subscribe to the war your kid podcast
because it's not coming out quite as
consistently at this time but it is a
great podcast for you or for your kids
to listen to to get them on the path
yeah they can also if you have kids
that's a good oh if you have kids it's
definitely a good one if you don't have
kids it's not a bad one yeah you can
learn some real fundamental those are
lessons that you kind of forget you know
that's what I mean I also get to warrior
kids soap Irish Oaks ranch calm got a
young Aiden warrior kid making soap yeah
interesting met having his own business
yeah throwing some support whatever
Irish Oaks ranch calm real soap to by
the way yeah it's like the soap kit
online and put my flavor in there and
sell it you can do that oh I didn't know
you could do that how that do you even
know that you know all kinds of weird
knowledge all right don't forget about
YouTube and that's where you can see
echoes legit videos and when you get
done watching the video make sure you
know less we do have a YouTube channel
that's the point that is the point
because you know if you like the video
version or you didn't know there was a
video version you can leave comments
there too yeah I read them yeah I read
YouTube comments even though Joe Rogan
tells me not to yeah because you do
that's a slippery slope because if a
comment comes and it like it's safe
what's the worst can comment is the kind
that's true or kinda true that like just
like are you're saying like it won't hit
you it's not a hard punch what's the
more indirect fire it's an indirect fire
but more effective like you know in your
neck or something you know think that it
has to be a little bit true I actually I
think I've told you this before but I
was one night I was reading YouTube
comments to my oldest daughter about
because they were and I forget it was it
wasn't our podcast it was it was a
different podcast a podcast that maybe
people weren't as much on both of the
program so that's a lot of really
colorful figures yeah yeah so I think
just Joe Rogan saying to you like don't
read them and this is why it doesn't say
like that he just he doesn't say it like
hey hey chuckle don't know oh you can't
read the YouTube comments man he'll say
it like that yes and that's what I mean
so you just knowing that allows you to
go in and like okay you can read them
and you just got to know that that's
accessible mostly reaching out with
Jordan Peterson like says he reads but
like they impact him yes no he doesn't
no no Joe Rogan need to tell him that
you gotta tell him hey that's like
that's not a normal comment section is
what I'm saying it's not like on
Instagram where it's like hey you know
it's like it's just different the
dynamic Brad I used to make these videos
you know this but I used to make these
videos like that you know parodies of
like Darth Vader goes on dates and then
I made this one cause you put those on
my channel on our channel on their
channel people still watch I mean
they're funny but I made this one a
bikini light saber battle it's like you
know glory in them they're just fighting
with light sabers at the beach or
whatever role well you don't you know
people watching but man I look at the
comments on that man it's like people I
think someone wanted me to die he said
whoever made this should die like
literally said that I was like what was
they hating about it what were they
hating about that he was dumb okay which
it is by the way yeah it's like two
girls they're mad at something and then
they fight light saber and then like she
one girl kills the other one and then
like Spider Man comes out is basically
all the props that I had at my house is
like makeup video yeah it was like used
um for sure but right you don't have to
say that kind comments like I got a dino
because it's dog the point is yeah you
get it you got to kind of know that
that's not a normal comment so yeah
YouTube there but you know I get it I
get good entertainment out of it it's
pretty fun also got psychological
warfare that's on iTunes Google Play and
be three platforms and that is a
album with tracks about how to overcome
various stages of weakness that you
might occur that might occur during your
day that's all we're gonna say about
that one's good
that's very concise yeah it's Jocko
though by the way it's on the track so
that's something also on it on it
dot-com slash Jocko this is where I get
all my kettlebells and socks like I
mentioned it seems odd like why just get
socks from on it because they're
freaking dope you ever watch do you ever
look at the socks on on it they're
freaking good yeah really good you want
a flex on the guys pattern I got all of
them so weird flex but okay ya know when
you want to flex it the at the people at
the TSA I keep I keep wanting to use the
term flex like in its modern way as my
kids use it and I keep wanting to use it
yeah keep trying man yeah I think you're
doing pretty good but no I haven't
really appropriately used it yet well
you used weird flex but okay on to me
not about me like you're saying about
someone else no no cuz Casey had a video
that was called that Oh weird flex but
okay
and that's when I realized it was a
thing that that that's an actual thing
yeah weird flex but okay know you told
me it was a thing yeah like that yeah I
don't use it I want to use it but it's
sort of humblebrag right not like weird
almost it's yeah it's like you're
bragging about something kind of weird
to brag about but cool man do what you
do kind of thing oh that's what the
expert Casey's video was weird flex with
what okay was about he was in him he's
in a movie and he was kind of like
flexing that he was in a movie yeah and
he was like but okay yeah it'd be more
like hey like I can turn my eyelids
inside out okay because flex on it this
is where you get your fitness that rowdy
you know Howard we all have home gyms
most of us yeah and you know you want a
date you want some more kettlebells you
know some jump ropes battle ropes like
stuff more good stuff to keep you on the
path keep you in shape that's where you
go on it dot
if you want to eat your mind in shape
your brain in shape then you should read
if you want to read some books that I
wrote then cool you can read Mikey in
the Dragons best children's book ever
for children under the age of six voted
by me and you yeah and our children and
our children actually someone asked my
daughter
my middle daughter the other day what's
your favorite book of your dad's
and she said Mikey and the Dragons
interesting yeah my daughter didn't we
didn't have any kind of official like oh
what's the best one but the one that she
always reaches for or pushes for is
where the warrior kid
- she likes marks mission so there's
that so there might be the Dragons
there's way the warrior kid - Mark's
mission there's way the quarry warrior
kid one we just call away the warrior
kid soon to be way the warrior kid three
writing is complete
John Bozek is knee-deep in the art right
now and that will be coming out in the
spring I'm gonna get it on Amazon for
pre-order as early as I possibly can so
we don't have another scenario like we
had with Mikey the Dragons where we
bought you all bought a lot of them and
I didn't have them all on hand let's say
I did give them everybody everybody by
Christmas so look for that one way the
warrior Kid 3 will be coming out and
then of course we got discipline comes
freedom Field Manual which is awesome to
see that impact people and it's also a
good gift to give to people that maybe
need a little help yeah just gotta steer
them in the right direction extreme
ownership and the dichotomy leadership
those are the leadership books that I
wrote with my brother lave babban and
they will help you with your
organization and in your business and in
your life lead and win also we got
national on front which is my leadership
consultancy it's me
it's lave Bab and JP to Nell Dave Burke
Flynn Cochran Mike's relly Mike bimah
there's a picture that echoes into the
picture on the website yeah but he's not
he's not
one of the leadership instructors he is
one of the leadership instructor filmers
all right
hey man I'm on the website so that's
really all so what we do is we solve
problems through leadership go national
on front comm for that we also have the
muster coming up to 2019 it's gonna be
May 23rd and 24th in Chicago September
19th and 20th in Denver and December 4th
and 5th in Sydney Australia
check out extreme ownership calm
they all have sold out and this will
salt sell out as well and when you go to
that you're gonna get granular
explanations multiple angles on how to
work and apply this stuff and if you
can't come to a muster guess what you
can go somewhere else can go to EF
online.com this is what we put together
took us about nine months to film put
together design its me and the rest of
the a tional on front team training
leadership through technology and it's
available for we really designed it for
enterprise for companies that we work
with that have 48,000 employees and we
can't travel the globe and train them
all so we put this stuff online and it's
also available now direct to consumer
DFL muncom and also we have EF overwatch
EF overwatch comm where we are
connecting proven leaders from combat
aviation and from Special Operations and
we're plugging them into companies that
need leadership to win at their mission
so get it go to EF overwatch comm if you
need that and if you want to pass on
lessons learned to us we are kickin it
on the interwebs on Twitter on Instagram
and on Facebook
echo is that echo Charles and I am at
jakka willing and of course thanks to
all of our military personnel around the
world who stand their ground to protect
us and also thank you to our police and
law enforcement the firefighters the
paramedics and EMTs the correctional
officers the folks on border patrol in
all the first responders who stand their
ground here at home to protect us and
everyone else I always say that time is
short but most of us have more than six
seconds the six seconds that corporal
Jonathan Yale and Lance Corporal jordan
Herger had to make the ultimate decision
and the ultimate sacrifice they could
have had more time had they run away but
they sacrificed it all they gave up
their time but we we still have time to
time they gave to us so don't waste it
not six minutes of it not six seconds of
it not one second of it none of it get
out there every second of every day they
get after it and until next time this is
echo and Jocko